Otterly Noah is a prolific plagiarist. >> Vasquez starts
the shot as an amorphous blob before the AI starts to put a mouth
on her cheek. In this shot here with Vasquez, it tries to read
her face at first as an amorphous blob because it doesn't recognize
her face is a face. Earlier today, Ottery Noah was accused of
stealing multiple edits, including ripping graphics directly
from a YouTuber named Shamu and his video on Tech. When I originally
saw the evidence, I decided to do a bit more digging. Now, I
will not be focusing most of my time on the allegations Shamu
is making, though I find them credible. Simply want to put out
the damn evidence I found, and there's quite a lot. To briefly
explain the intro, you saw a clip first from a channel named
Norell in a video called AI can ruin movies now. Two, aliens
and true wise on 4K. >> Vasquez starts the shot as an amorphous
blob before the AI starts to put a mouth on her cheek. Nurell
released his video on May 26, 2024 where Ottoy Noah put out his
video how anti-woke culture purposely misappropriates media on
January 15th, 2026.
You'll notice the graphics are the exact same with the blue circle
and the identical line about the amorphous blob. >> In
this shot here with Vasquez, it tries to read her face at first
as an amorphous blob because it doesn't recognize her face is
a face. In the same Otter we know a video. They steal more from
Nurell, taking the graphics and a snippet of the script. >> And
Tom Arnold, a spectacle to behold in his prime. Looks to be in
the early stages of Emperor Palpatinesism.
This shot here makes Tom Arnold look like he's turning into an
amalgamation of Emperor Palpatine and Donald Trump. So that's
pretty bad. But things got a lot worse when I started searching
around Twitter. I found that this wasn't the first time Otto
Noah was accused of plagiarism. I found Vincent Pavarell had
accused Otino Noah of plagiarizing his video, the worst movie
take I've ever seen in 2025, back in December. Thankfully for
us, Otter Noah hasn't taken down his video at the time of editing
this. It's called debunking Jester Bell's abysmal anti-woke take
on 2025 movies, released 4 weeks after Vincent's video. Most
of the plagiarism will be Otterly Noah stealing the script from
Vincent's video with a slight remix. All clips will be in chronological
order. I will provide timestamps in the description to verify
>> This year kicked off with Captain America: Brave New
World. >> No, this year kicked off with Companion, Betterman,
and Dogman. >> This year kicked off with Captain America:
Brave New World. >> Uh, no, this year did not start off
with Captain America: Brave New World. This year started off
with Companion, Betterman, and Dogman in January of
>> And I'm even skipping on a couple. One of them, Betterman,
was a massive box office disaster. But let's not use box office
as a metric to determine a film's quality for a moment. >> Betterman
was actually a pretty decent and unique music biopic about the
British singer Robbie Williams that unfortunately ended up being
a big flop for Paramount. But let's take a step back and not
use box office to determine whether a film is actually good or
not. Jester Bell >> having a unique energy to it. incredible
dance sequences >> with some absolutely gorgeous dance
sequences all throughout >> and an interesting twist of
turning the star into a CGI monkey that actually works when you
watch the film and also a pretty unique gimmick of having Robin
Williams portrayed as a CGI monkey to sort of symbolize how he's
always felt like an outcast party animal throughout most of his
life. Snow White came out in March. So, let's go to that specific
month and see what were the notable titles that came out. We
had Mickey 17, Novocane, Black Bag, and Looney Tunes. to the
day the earth blew up, which is really good and underrated. By
the way, for those who love animation, I suggest you guys check
it out. So, you went out of your way once again to watch Snow
White, a movie that already looked bad from the marketing. And
instead of watching something like I don't know, Looney Tunes:
The Day the Earth Brewle Up, a much better movie that was also
in theaters around this exact time. >> And uh later, the
Minecraft movie. Like >> it is a mid movie. >> The
Minecraft movie. Like even the >> the Minecraft movie is
mid. Yes. But you know what else came out in April that was admit
sinners. All right, you don't care about it. >> But again,
that came out in April. And you know what else came out in April?
Sinners, which you yourself admitted you didn't see before. >> Then
there's still the accountant too and drop. Both wellreceived.
>> You could have gone to see The Accountant 2. >> Tron
Aries did not have girl boss in the >> Tron Aries didn't
contain a girl boss at >> I'm not saying Greta Lee's character
was well written, but not once in the movie did she ever belittle
the male characters around her. Eve Kim may have not been the
most compelling character ever, but she wasn't a girl bot. >> She
literally spent a good chunk of the ending being trapped and
eventually saved by Aries. >> She spent most of the movie
being trapped and had to be rescued by Aries at the very end.
In fact, >> so that's what I was able to find in about
2 hours of looking. I wanted to get this out immediately and
see utterly Noah's response before I look any deeper. Other than
that, thanks for